I spent an entire career 20 years
working here in New York and dealing
with the media and you know let's be
clear the media has helped shape my
career but I wanted to you know have a
platform for athletes that they can
speak directly to the fans and their own
words and first person point of view
unfiltered unbiased and I think it's
something that's needed I've spoken to
athletes from all different sports and
they're excited about it so that excites
me how involved are you going to be you
know whether it's you know meeting with
different companies are partnerships
with AOL and legendary pictures and blue
jean network and you know I enjoyed
being behind the scenes and and get an
opportunity to meet some partners that
strategic partners are going to help us
out so are you involved in recruiting
some of the players all right now I've
talked to some of the players I wouldn't
call it recruitment because players want
to do this you know they want to talk
about the adding a lot of time people
look at players like they're
one-dimensional that's the only thing
that they do but players have all kind
of interests and you know we want to
give them the tools to develop the
content that they want to share with the
fans and like I said that's what excites
me you know it because I was looking
through the players Tribune and some of
the articles great articles you know
Russell Wilson wrote one Jason Collins
as well about coming out as a gay
athlete I think about that though and I
say Derek their social media out there
now right there's Twitter there's
Facebook there's Instagram and LinkedIn
and others other avenues to say those
same things so why would they come to
the players well I we sort of it's
almost like a long-form Twitter i mean i
don't i'm not i don't have a twitter
account so it was 140 50 60 characters i
don't know what it is 115 it's kind of
hard I think at times to say an entire
message or an entire story or point of
view in that little you know amount of
space so like I said athletes are always
going to continue to do that you know
we're giving them tools to develop
produce curate anything that they want
and athletes love it i mean this day and
age athletes like sharing everything
with the world so it's a little bit
different when i came up but now they
enjoy it so it's it's fun for us